nearly
811 million people worldwide are hungry
today and 45 million people are on the
edge of famine across 43 countries
how do you feel how do you make sense of
that many people suffering from hunger
and famine in the world today
i don't know if i can make sense of it
lex i mean i think um
it's
deeply disturbing to me
that as a global community we've allowed
this number of people
to go hungry when the food to feed them
exists and the resources
to feed them exists i think the thing
that disturbs me most about those
figures
is that
many of those
who are starving today or going hungry
today
um
are
the net result of war
and intentional acts by leaders
to starve entire populations and that's
the most deeply disturbing part to me
um
you know your history
and we all know that you know deeply
embedded in the geneva conventions post
world war ii
the intent of one of those articles was
to
ban the use of starvation as a weapon of
war
because of what hitler did during world
war ii
that's been reiterated multiple times
over the years in international
humanitarian law including in 2018
because of the saudi blockade over yemen
and yet to this day
starvation as a weapon of war continues
to be used in ethiopia
obviously in ukraine right now and in
yemen with the blockade over the country
and that that disgusts me
that the law is in place but it won't be
enforced by the international bodies and
the nation-states that are that make up
the international community
so when the starvation is a result
of human actions human decisions that's
especially
painful to make sense of for me
personally yeah i think that if you and
i sitting here didn't eat for three days
um and had to you know lay our head on
the sidewalk for a couple nights i think
we would take
you know hunger
and homelessness a lot more seriously
and i think that's
for some reason that's missing at this
moment in history tragically and i think
until that we can generate enough
empathy
um that's immediate for all of us to
understand what that means to go hungry
i'm not sure we're gonna sort of marshal
the the global community to solve it
i did just that by the way
faster for three days
recently
is fundamentally different
i think because
the thing that would be terrifying to me
is not the fasting but the hopelessness
at the end of the fast like uh i
wouldn't know when the next meal is
coming yeah i always had the freedom to
have the meal yeah the fear for not just
your own
ability to eat and survive but your
families if there's loved ones that's
the other thing i don't have i'm single
so
i feel like the worst suffering is
watching
somebody you love that you're supposed
to be a caretaker of
and you can't take care of them
and if all of that is caused by
leaders
in
in um as as a weapon of war that
is especially painful so how can we
um
how can we help
what are the ways to
help how do we alleviate this the
suffering
well i think on the you know
i think on the humanitarian front we
have to be aggressive
um and attentive
and intervene in significant ways and i
think on the political front we have to
hold
uh players accountable
for their actions so the leaders that
start the war so you when you say we
have to speak up about the the decisions
and the humans making those decisions
yeah that lead to the stuff for example
let's make it concrete so you know when
i was i don't want to jump ahead but
when i was filming hunger ward in yemen
um
you know i met
a mother
who when she gave birth weighed 70
pounds the mother weighed 70 pounds
and
so her
daughter
was starved in the womb
right
when she was born
um there was she was born into a world
with no breast milk
very little formula right so she was
starved before birth
she was born into a world where she
continued to be starved right by a
mother who herself was starved
i watched that child her name is sila
die in front of me
right
acila had no chance for
all those things we hoped for for a
child in this world
she she didn't have a chance to grow up
she didn't have a chance to
discover love she didn't have a chance
to have a career she was robbed of all
of those things because of the insidious
nature of hunger that she was born into
she didn't have to die
she she
you know she was not starving she her
mother was being starved because of the
blockade over the country now who
instituted that blockade
mbs in saudi arabia with the
reinforcement and sort of tacit approval
of the united states our own
government here and so there are people
who are responsible for the starvation
of children and i think we need to hold
them accountable
now that's incredibly difficult to do
but just because it's difficult doesn't
mean it not it ought not to be done
you